bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8
week-end tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 29 avril
antoine gosselin chargé des missions
sports du service événementiel de l'île
des loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
est notre invité il vient nous présenter
les activités du week-end beach volley
et bubble foot
en écho à la journée commémorative de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé le 10 mai
prochain
la médiathèque jean rosselot de
guyancourt présente jusqu'au 15 mai
prochain une nouvelle exposition hommage
de l' esclavage 110 des marais
présidente de l'association des
commerçants de cerner la ville et tony
bastion responsable artistique du
cabaret du bout des prêts nous
rejoindront dans quelques instants avec
eux nous évoquerons la deuxième édition
du concours de chant de la vallée de
chevreuse et nous
et nous démarrons cette édition avec
antoine gosselin bonjour jours alors
vous êtes chargé de mission sport pour
le service événementiel de l'île des
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines et
aura lieu donc ce week-end deux
activités pour une association vous
allez nous expliquer ça à savoir du
beach volley et du bubble foot alors
dans quel cadre ont lieu ces deux
activités
alors en fait donc c'est une association
qui vient donc ce week-end sur
l'hébergement collectif de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines et
donc ils ont demandé à réserver en fait
un créneau bubble foot ont comme nous on
appelle au crazy ball mais après c'est
ça se rejoint forcément donc donc un
créneau baveux le foot est un créneau
bijoux et du coup on leur a proposé tout
ça et donc ils viennent ils viennent ce
week-end pour pour s'amuser voilà donc
nous le crazy babel en fait c est donc
une activité
donc ça joue plutôt à quatre contre
quatre donc c'est des personnes donc qui
rentrent qui disent en fait dans des
dans des bulles dans des énormes bulles
transparentes en fait et donc les règles
ça rejoint un petit peu les règles du
foot
ouais voilà les règles donc ça rejoint
un petit peu les règles du foot est donc
en fait le but c'est tout simplement
pour récupérer la maîtrise du ballon
c'est de foncer dans les adversaires
pour récupérer le ballon et pour aller
marquer des buts voilà donc vraiment les
règles c'est traversé le terrain pour
aller marquer donc c'est ça ouais tout à
fait don il faut voilà faut récupérer le
ballon et bien sûr essayer d'éviter les
adversaires même si c'est un peu
compliqué et voilà ça soit 4 contre 4
vous disent eh oui 4 contre 4 après il
ya des remplaçants ce parce qu'en fait
c'est une activité qui est mine de rien
quand même assez physique s'agit déjà de
porter la bulle je sais pas exactement
combien ça pèse mais c'est ouais c'est
quand même assez lourd pour les enfants
ils peuvent avoir un petit peu de mal
des fois apporté la bulle mais après
c'est ces pratiques à partir de 11 ans
donc donc ces confessions démence de 15
ça va de 30 à 45 minutes après
on modifie les créneaux selon les
demandes des groupes évidemment mais
ouais c'est à l'origine 30 45 minutes
parce que comme je vous ai dit c'est
assez fatiguant surtout connu du soleil
ça peut vite chauffé à l'intérieur donc
ton voilà donc on précise que ses
activités ont été organisées à
destination d'une association ce week
end mais tout particulier est libre de
s'inscrire aux adresses qui vont
s'afficher à l'écran aussi bien sur
votre site internet que sur le mail qui
va s'afficher
donc c'est vraiment à destination de
tout public est ce que il ya des
conditions d'âge à respecter donc c'est
à partir de 11 ans voilà c'est ouvert à
tous les publics donc comme vous l'avez
dit les particuliers les associations
les entreprises et les structures
jeunesse donc là en fait pendant les
vacances de pâques on en avait on a
ouvert donc le village loisirs
donkey qui était ouvert pour les
structures jeunesse et les centres de
loisirs qui voit là pendant toutes les
vacances scolaires on ne trouve donc en
vacances de pâques aux vacances de la
toussaint et bien sûr pour les vacances
d'été
voilà en fait on propose on a une
entre 15 et 20 activités qu'on propose
toute l'année on essaie de trouver des
nouvelles activités tous les ans et donc
en fait les groupes nous réserve des
créneaux en choisissant leurs activités
nous met en place derrière qui l'ont
demandé voilà pour toujours dans ce but
de s'amuser de prendre du plaisir tout
en pratiquant des activités physiques et
sportives
alors donc ça c'est pendant le village
voisin il ya également du beach volley
pendant le village loisirs et c'est
l'activité à laquelle est couplé le
bubble foot ce week-end oui après en ce
moment c'est pas toujours forcément le
cas tous les jours mais après dès qu'il
ya un petit peu de soleil oui forcément
c'est une activité qui plaît beaucoup
parce que forcément sur les sports de
l'espoir de sable qu'on propose au beach
volley c'est une activité web qui
revient souvent
ça joue voilà de 2 à 5 personnes par
équipe donc donc ça ça peut me dis que
le volet on est sur les mêmes règles
c'est à peu près les mêmes règles
sensiblement après
le beach-volley forcément un petit peu
plus d'acrobaties vu qu'on est dans le
sable pour les jeunes en plus il adore
ça se jeter dans le sable et tout ça
donc c'est bien fun comme activité alors
l'instant vous nous parliez du village
loisirs organisait les loisirs pendant
toutes les vacances scolaires
mais le développement de du vêlage wazir
de ce concept les tcc le village sportif
d'été donc en fête qui aura lieu cette
année du 6 juillet au 5 août et donc en
fait il est financé par par la région et
donc il permet c'est à peu près le
sensiblement le même but que cole
village de loisirs sauf que là comme
c'est financé par la région il ya
évidemment beaucoup plus de structures
jeunesse et donc beaucoup plus de jeunes
qui viennent et donc c'est aussi pour
ouvrir les portes pour les jeunes des
quartiers prioritaires qui n'ont pas
forcément la possibilité de partir en
vacances l'été et nous voilà ce alors
c'est vraiment à destination des jeunes
oui bah c'est à destination des 11 17
ans des quartiers prioritaires et donc
voilà ils viennent pratiquer énormément
d'activités tout au long de ces cinq
semaines
on est bien content de les accueillir en
tout cas et ça fait plaisir mais donc
multitude d'activités organisées aussi
bien à destination des jeunes pour les
villageois zim que cet été et sinon donc
le public est invité à s'inscrire aux
activités que vous proposez dont le
beach volley ce week-end et le bubble
foot
merci antoine gosselin d'absurdité avec
nous en plateau et dont je rappelle que
vous pouvez vous inscrire à ses
activités pour le week end aux adresses
qui s'affiche à l'écran aussi bien sur
le site internet de l'île des loisirs
que le mail et on reste en sport une
information pour le golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
le parcours de l'albatros l'un des plus
techniques de france et qui accueillera
les joueurs pendant l'open de france de
golf rouvrira ses portes aux golfeurs ce
week-end après neuf mois de travaux les
trous numéros 16 et 11 ont été
remodelées pour accueillir les grandes
compétitions nationales et
internationales comme la ryder cup en
on écoute le super intendant du parcours
alejandro reyes pour les taux n'est dit
les trouve que pour les usa matin ça va
être plus simple le monde
on m'a samus et savait plus à mon sens
on a fait les soldes s'approche et que
ça va être moins compliquée pour les
joueurs amateurs
mais par contre pour les duels
professionnel et il y a il y a pas mal
d'obstacles qui est bon qu'ils vont
faire la tâche est difficile on en 2018
pour l'open de france
une proposition d'exposition maintenant
pour votre week end en journée à la
journée commémorative de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé le 10 mai prochain
la médiathèque jean rosselot de
guyancourt présente jusqu'au 15 mai une
nouvelle exposition images de l'
esclavage
une exposition pour mettre en lumière le
traitement cinématographique du thème de
l' esclavage afin de sensibiliser les
gens autour de ce pan de l'histoire
encore méconnu une trentaine d'euros
n'en sélectionner différents documents
et une dizaine de dvd
ça va de tous vous avez glory django
unchained qui est sorti et pas très
longtemps et puis après vous avez
amistad vous n'êtes pas mal de films en
fait sur le sujet donc ça c'est assez
complet voilà qui traite des différents
mouvements moment ça peut être la traite
en afrique l'arrivée le voyage la
rébellion la fuite et s'est donc et pas
mal de tous les grands les grands
mouvements grands événements durant la
traite de l'esclavagé jusqu'à la
libération et l'abolition
alors après l' esclavage s'est pas
uniquement la traite négrière c'est
également l'esclavagé en birmanie où
après on a on a élargi le sujet sur l'
esclavage par rapport au travail par
rapport à plein de choses donc c'est un
sujet qui as est assez vaste
et on continue à présent littérature
comme chaque vendredi le pavé du canal
de saint quentin en yvelines vous fait
partager sa sélection littéraire
aujourd'hui c'est stéphanie férial qui
vous présente la mpt prodigieuse et le
nouveau roman
voilà l'ami prodigieuse est le nouveau
nom d'hélène afférentes qui sont les
deux premier tome d'une saga absolument
exceptionnel italienne une grande
fresque romanesque dans le naples alors
le premier commence à la fin des années
50 dans le naples 2e on est dans les
années 60 et on suit en fait tout un
quartier très populaire à naples et
notamment deux jeunes filles deux amis
donc dans le premier roman
elle commence l oms septembre on les
suit sur une dizaine d'années puis donc
de 17 ans à 25 27 ans à peu près pour le
second pour l'instant donc lna et lina
très très différentes l'une de l'autre
très très lié très amis effectivement
mais ce qui a surtout très intéressant
c'est qu'on suit tout le quartier et
notamment les autres amis qu'il y a et
c'est un quartier très populaire
populaire dans le bon sens du terme et
avec plein de petits métiers artisanaux
et moi ce que j'ai besoin de trouver
génial dans ce roman c'est qu'on suit
ces deux jeunes filles donc là pour
l'instant sur sur 15 20 ans à peu près
et comment réussir finalement à sortir
aussi de son milieu ce que c'est ça aux
fins qui m'a plu dans le roman c'est que
là pour le coup c'était un vrai roman
social ce qu'il faut les airs dans
l'ordre enfin ce qu'il faut avoir une
amie prodigieuse comprendre oui il vaut
mieux parce qu'en plus ça se suivent
vraiment dire que là où ce terme on
al'impression vraiment de records de le
suivre page à page là où elle a terminé
un événement qui se termine dans le
premier et le premier est le premier
événement est là est vraiment c'est le
dernier événement qui se termine dans le
premier tome c'est une prédiction
vraiment parce que d'abord elles sont
attachants tout le quartier est vraiment
attachant moi je suis prête à mettre à
l'italien pour venir les deux autres qui
s'y pendre heures avenue allende
il a encore deux autres qui sont pas
encore traduits
et on ouvre une page septième art
aurélie sergent du grenier à sel de
trappes vous présente
nous lançons gaillette najafi le coup de
coeur du grenier à sel cette semaine
sera le film nolens hong un film iranien
de hayat najafi qui suit le projet de sa
jeune soeur sara qui et compositrice
mais également musicienne et surtout
chanteuse dans son projet de vouloir
noter un concert solo de femmes elles
vont tenter de convaincre le
gouvernement iranien de pouvoir
organiser ce concert alors que même le
gouvernement interdit aux femmes de
pouvoir chanter seul sur scène donc
c'est un film de lutte c'est un film où
deux femmes deux femmes fortes pour la
liberté de chanter et c'est aussi un
film dans le dispositif
cinématographique est très simple nous
plonge au coeur de la société iranienne
ça a été aussi pour cette jeune sarah un
vrai combat parce que elle se met le
face à la caméra à nu sans porter le
voile en chantant des hymnes
révolutionnaires et temps
tout à fait subversives c'est vraiment
une résistante aller au coeur de sa
sollicité en train de lutter pour la
liberté d'expression
les d'égalité des femmes et nos atouts
elle est très bien
la musique venez le voir au grenier à
sel ce film est une perle c'est un
diamant c'est un bijou il ne faut pas
louper on a deux séances dimanche et
mardi de la semaine prochaine
venez découvrir ce documentaire qui est
bien plus qu'un documentaire qui une
histoire vibrante fraternelles entre
l'iran et la france est 7e art toujours
on regarde maintenant vos réactions à la
fiche des nouveautés de cette semaine et
beaucoup d'action que ça tout le temps
n'avait jamais assez encore mais
franchement cette espagne après le fait
qu'ils se battent entre eux c'est un peu
nul parce qu'on a et puis de les voir
ensemble mais ça me de l'action donc ça
va c'est bien moi c'était bien ce qu'on
attendait
le premier donc avec tous ces
personnages réunis c'était magnifique
avant on a recommandé pour toute
personne née mon genre
on va plutôt bien dynamique des petits
moments nous mais sinon c'était plutôt
agréable
les enfants bien humaine qui s'excuse et
viennent de nous rejoindre en plateau
110 démarrer bonjour bonjour vous êtes
et la président de l'association des
commerçants de cerner la ville et tony
bastian bonjour alors vous vous êtes le
responsable artistique du cabaret du
bout des prés du bout du pré de cerner
la ville du goût des prix du bout des
prêts la première était la bonne
donc vous venez nous parler du concours
de chant qui aura lieu dimanche de 14 à
16 heures au cabaret du bout des
précédents décerner la ville
présentez-nous un peu ce lieu qui est
une ancienne écurie du dix septième
siècle exactement c'est une skin écuries
à sa appartient la ferme du bout des
prêts qui est un restaurant et ce
bâtiment était vide et on a souhaité en
faire un bâtiment un petit peu spécial
donc on en a fait un cabaret ça fait
trois ans qu'il est ouvert et petit à
petit l'oiseau fait son nid plus toi
bien le nom n'est pas anodin non puisque
on a voulu garder justement le nom de la
ferme puisqu'on est dans une ferme la
ferme s'appelle la ferme du bout des
prêts donc on disait que le cabaret du
bout des prêts ça convenait totalement
le fait de s'installer cerner la ville à
proximité de paris c'était un choix ont
volonté si on presque dire c'est le
destin tout simplement qui nous a
ramenés dans ce camp là et on s'est bien
amusés dans la ferme qui a d'autres
activités là bas et on a développé et
puis on s'est installé à côté donc voilà
c'est juste pour ça donc différents
spectacles dans votre cabaret mais
dimanche ce dont on parle c'est la
deuxième édition du concours de chant de
cerner la ville qui est organisée en
partenariat avec votre association 110
démarré voilà
expliquez-nous l'initiative de ce projet
alors en fait l'association
des commerçants de cerner la ville a été
créé il y à peu plus de deux ans et dans
un esprit de convivialité d'amitié avec
les commerçants artisans restaurateurs
boulangers artistes comme tony ici
présents et de là nous avons mis en
place différents projets dont ce
concours de chant qui depuis deux ans
enfin on arrive à sa deuxième édition va
nous permettre peut-être de découvrir
encore une ou un prodige de chant comme
l'année dernière avec laure biche et qui
a été notre lauréate
alors est ce qu elle est justement de
découvrir de nouveaux talents il
s'agissait de créer une synergie entre
les différents acteurs du territoire de
développer la vallée de chevreuse tout à
fait oui oui le but étant vraiment comme
je voulais dit d'avoir un esprit de
convivialité et de rencontre et les
cerner gien et puis les gens de la
vallée autrement que d'être dans la rue
à se dire bonjour au revoir et puis de
créer une atmosphère vraiment très
sympathique et pour l'instant du retour
que l'on peut en avoir
on est très satisfait je le suis moi
même je lave aux présentes étaient
d'ailleurs les retombées de la première
édition les retombées ont été fort
sympathique déjà par les enfants qui eux
mêmes se sentait déjà prêt dès le
lendemain à choisir leur chanson pour la
préparation du concours
un an plus tard donc ça déjà c'est une
super motivation pour nous pour
continuer ce beau projet et puis ensuite
par le reste des animations nous pouvons
faire au fur et à mesure du temps c'est
vrai que cette évolution nous permet
vraiment et nous donne beaucoup dans
veepee rien de tel que les paroles
d'enfants et leurs leur grand sourire
pour nous permettre de continuer c'est
clairement génial alors vous le dise
la lauréate de la première édition il
s'agit de leurs déchets est ce que pour
elle c'est a servi de tremplin
ou est ce qu'elle en est elle est jeune
mais ça lui sert en tout cas de david
aller plus loin je lis vos téléphones
n'y a pas très longtemps donc elle va
revenir pour la 2e 2e édition en tant
que guest est justement
et quand je les appelais l'été elle
était ravie elle a déjà participé à
quelques premières parties de nos de nos
spectacle au cabaret c'était une grande
fierté puis pour moi aussi parce que je
trouve ça j'ai eu la chance dans ma
jeunesse aussi d'avoir des opportunités
de faire des premières parties et je
trouve que c'est bien aussi de pouvoir
leur donner envie tout simplement
d'aller d'aller face à un public prendre
des cours de chant c'est bien mais c'est
mieux ça me rassure sur le terrain tony
bastion expliquez nous donc ce concours
est ouvert à qui il est ouvert à tous
les enfants et les ados donc enfin tous
les mineurs l'idée était de faire un
concours dans l'esprit de l'association
c'est à dire conviviale l'idée était de
faire découvrir aussi les jeunes talents
de cerner la ville et du coin aussi
puisque ayem ça s'étale maintenant un
petit peu tout autour du département
fait et cette année on a ouvert trois
catégories mais dernière on avait fait
une seule catégorie et c'est vrai que
entre les petits bouts de chou de six
ans qui chante et les ados qu'on 16 17
ans performances différentes forcément
et puis bat d ceci dit c'est pas souvent
les plus les plus âgés qui étaient les
plus sûres devant le micro et pour
revenir à ce que disait sans dit tout à
l'heure ça a été une vraie une vraie
bouffée de voir ce concours parce que
les enfants quand ils chantent ils n'ont
pas peur
finalement les parents ont très peur
pour leurs enfants mais c'est c'est moi
je me suis retrouvé à être ému de les
voir chanter parce que complètement
c'est très prenant très prenant comme
sensation c'est alors ces trois cas de
royal et 6 8 ans les 9 12 ans c'est ça
mais ce serait tout à fait quinze ans
parce qu'on n'a pas eu plus âgés
peut-être par peur on a eu une quelques
ados l'année dernière et puis certaines
que je côtoie encore et qui viennent de
temps en temps pas prendre des cours de
chant mais prendre des conseils ont
refusé cette année parce que voilà
alors on est sûr que le style musical
avec ses enfants
c'est très drôle parce qu'en fait on sur
les trois catégories on décèle
effectivement tout vous tous les tous
les tubes de disney ou houle et les
chanteurs ou chanteuses en vogue c'est à
dire louane kenji girac pipi disney on a
encore un libéré délivrer cette année
raconte que les enfants d'ailleurs oui
non pas que les enfants ses vrais
parents en avaient marre mais en 2e
catégorie on a des chansons étrangement
plus des années 80 70 80 et des
chanteurs français sardou le normand
c'est assez rigolo
et puis puis la troisième catégorie là
on est dans la plaine modernité on sent
que son qu'ils sont tous pleine actu
voilà y'a un par un impôt spécial et
auquel vous tenez particulièrement bien
rond le sait très actif pour votre cabas
exactement fait c'est alors on pourrait
penser que c'est un par un pour pour
aider juste pour l'image c'est un ami
avant tout et c'est quelqu'un qui a
découvert le cabaret par hasard et qui
qui est revenu plusieurs fois le voir
donc voilà et comme c'était la première
guest qui venaient nous voir chez nous
et bien là on l'a demandé s'ils
voulaient bien que le parent est depuis
maintenant il s'investit beaucoup dans
dans toutes les opérations comme ce
concours de chant
il sera membre du jury aux côtés
d'autres vont peut-être d'autres vip
alors une personne qui est moins exposée
mais qui est metteur en scène qui a
d'ailleurs réalisé pas mal de choses
dans nos spectacles et qui a notamment
fait l'euro l' eurovision junior à une
certaine époque et u
vous avez que charles aznavour s'appelle
jean-françois varlet et puis sinon on a
on a effectivement isabelle morini-bosc
de l'émission de 2,8 et eider t elle qui
viendra être le troisième membre du jury
puisque le quatrième et le maire de
cerner la ville voilà qui est également
content d'y démarrer y aura bien sûr
louis ii ce voice voilà qui la
continuité paraît bonne
donc et le sera alors c'est vrai que
louis va nous faire l'honneur de chanter
avec l'ordre avec laure voilà dimanche
au concours de chant donc voilà pour
pour nous c'est tout un honneur comme
pour moi parce que je le précise c'était
un mes élèves à l'auto-école donc voilà
grande précision
mais voilà je voulais juste rajouter un
petit point petits grands points nous
aussi on a un vip très important sur qui
on compte au sein de l'association qui
pour nous est honni voilà qui est nôtre
notre présentateur notre ami notre
confident au sein d'associations donc
c'est vraiment super pour nous de
l'avoir avec nous et puis de pouvoir
partager quand même dans ce lieu du
cabaret qui vraiment magique et
magnifique et qui permet aux enfants aux
parents ou aux spectateurs d'être dans
un lieu superbe on va parler des on va
dire un mot sur les trois premiers prix
qui vont être maître remis aux
différentes catégories
donc pour les adolescents le premier
prix ça très beau premier prix s'étant
l'enregistrement studio exactement voilà
on s'est dit que l'on cherchait des prix
a donné et on se disait s'ils viennent
chanter c'est qu'ils ont un petit peu
envie de chanter et je trouve que à mon
époque j'aurais moi j'aurais aimé qu
effectivement plutôt que de m'offrir une
coupe ou même de l'argent offrir la
possibilité peut-être de continuer à
chanter à travers une démo quelque chose
donc l'idée c'est de leur donner
l'opportunité d'enregistrer un titre de
champion pour prolonger le rêve et puis
peut-être pourquoi pas s'en servir pour
aller
à se présenter dans des émissions comme
the voice par exemple ça peut être
intéressant
donc voilà c'est ça le premier prix pour
les 9 12 ans les enfants balades le but
du jeu c'est désormais en fait dans une
dans une émission de télé alors pas
qu'en tant qu'invité mais aussi
peut-être pour pouvoir prolonger le rêve
allait rencontrer quelques animateurs
donc vu les membres du jury
il ya des possibilités donc c'est on
verra en fonction de l'opportunité et
pour les petits les 6 8 ans alors les
petits c'est un petit peu une offre un
prix découverte pour eux l'idée c'est de
leur faire goûter puisqu'on est dans un
cabaret même si c'est un concours de
chant c'est leur faire goûter un petit
peu au one man show et est adapté il ya
un spectacle à paris qui se joue qui
s'appelle le wanted chaud et qui est un
one man show réservé aux enfants
voilà vraiment très rigolo très rigolo
voilà donc on s'est vraiment des prix
adaptés aussi bien à l'âge que à la
motivation première du concours oui et
puis y'a pas que ça il ya des petits
prix après des petites places de cinéma
y avoir là il ya plein de choses tout le
monde est gagnant
voilà ça c'est un moment convivial et
récompensé en plus à la fois j insiste
ce sont deux choses c'est que le
concours ne sera pas fait comme un
concours ce sera fait comme un spectacle
je motive les candidats à chaque fois en
leur disant vous allez maintenant faire
en skate devant vos parents vos amis
devant des gens que vous ne connaissez
pas et donc la première catégorie
passera l'ordre fera une petite
intervention la deuxième catégorie
passera louis fera son intervention est
la troisième catégorie jusqu'au à la
remise des prix voilà épanouissement
artistique sur scène attendu est avant
tout merci 110 démarrer et oignies
bastian d'avoir accepté notre invitation
et donc je rappelle que la deuxième
édition du concours de chant de cerner
la ville aura lieu au cabaret du bout
des prêts de la même ville de 14 à 16
heures et avant de nous quitter je vous
ai proposé quelques idées sorties pour
les prochains jours retrouvez mercredi 4
mai à 16h le monde sous les flaques une
pièce de théâtre jeune public le
professeur armand qu'invite un voyageur
de flacq à nous parler de ces mondes
alternatifs qui existe sous nos pieds
mercredi 4 mai 20h30 direction la
batterie de guyancourt pour retrouver le
trio formé par le grand contrebassiste
de jazz
avishai cohen le pianiste d'année daniel
d'or
et omri mor à la batterie
mon
bon
et enfin mercredi 4 mai 20h30 toujours
direction le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour retrouver
la pièce de théâtre la trilogie dû
revoir à l'occasion d'une exposition
qu'ils ne verront pas les personnages de
botho strauss mise en scène par benjamin
port et nous tendent un miroir et pose
une question cruciale comment vivre
ensemble et c'est déjà la fin de ce sept
huit week end merci de nous avoir suivis
vous pourrez retrouver l'émission sur
notre site internet je vous souhaite un
excellent week end